[Music]
[Applause]
hello today we're going to talk about
how to use go as a scripting language
when I talk to people other people about
this subject they usually ask why but I
hope because this is a dot goal
conference I don't have to convince you
but in case there are some heretics here
in the hall I still hear some points to
digest so we know that go is easy to
learn write and read it's a huge as
system of already ready code you just
can just go get what you want it's
compiled and strong and type if you use
it as a script other interpreted
languages basically when they run half
of the script then there is a typo and
your system is broken and inconsistent
state hopefully go we'll fix that and
it's low level enough for the different
system tasks what I particularly like
it's like more than easy integration
with C code some potential use cases
let's imagine a go build system for you
go projects why you use bison if you
have if you like go right we go code
prototyping and easier script implanting
sometimes you want your code to be in
the source form to stuck it into config
management systems or something like
that
and well basically anywhere where bison
is used now you can replace it with go
easily so ok how do we do that so what
do we need as an environment for a
proper script we need an operating
system we need a programming language
and an interpreter right so for an
operating system for the purposes of
this talk and the greater good we will
use Linux because it's the only real
operating system programming language is
obviously go and what about the
interpreter like we'll say how do you
run your go code in source form and
people would say oh there is this
official tool go run and maybe we can
use that so can we
let's take a simple go script is an
example it's a plain hello world program
and let's try to run it as a script go
run and you see the app by the way
although this these are slides this all
have been copy pasted from a real
terminal so don't worry it's it's like a
demo so yeah you can you can run this
your go script right right but we need
more right we from a script we need like
script to be able to parse common line
arguments we also need the scripts to
return proper error code to the
operating system because oftentimes you
like change the scripts and the complex
pipeline and return codes is the way how
they interact with each other and with
the operating system and also you don't
want to be typing go run every time you
run your go script you want just set the
executable bin and execute it as a
regular file so how do you do that let's
check if we can have an example of a
script with our properties so our script
will be slightly modified it accepts one
common line argument and on a specific
condition in my file with a exits with a
return code sorry
don't ask me what sorry is I don't
remember and finally how do you achieve
the executable part in like in Linux and
most unix-like operating system you do
it with a shebang line
so the shebang line is just the first
line in your script it starts with a
hash exclamation mark and the pasture to
the interpreter which among line does
its tells your operating system and keep
in mind that it tells your operating
system not your shell which interpreted
to use for the script and I will come
back to that later ok let's add a
shebang line called toy script here it
is we just add go run let's check if it
works if you try to execute this file it
will fail why because unlike many other
languages hash is not a valid commenting
go and people have been asking for this
feature can we make an exception just
for the shebang line and go maintainer
said
for some reason I don't know why I mean
there is a lengthy thread you can google
it so when somebody does not want to
like official maintains do not want
support feature like we go to the
community right so and like people on
Stack Overflow came up with a brilliant
and here like let's just exploit the
properties of specific shell so most
shell shells will try to execute your
file as is lineman line if you don't
have a shebang line and for file system
paths and UNIX double forward slash is
saying as equal for a single forward
slash but double forward slash is a
valid common angle so they replace a
shebang line with the this is my term I
call it shell is inline just by
replacing the hash with double forward
slash and adding these magic things to
make parameter passing work okay let's
try to execute it now but let's also
check if the parameter passing works so
you will see something like that so you
see the expected output but some garbage
in the end as well so what happened here
is the good the script was executed but
the bad thing and even the parameter
passing work but the bad thing is like
you also get some garbage apparently and
because they shall try to execute it the
first line it was the shell is in line
as I call it and then try to execute the
source file line-by-line itself and you
get all this garbage
so Stack Overflow people don't give up
yeah we can terminate we can terminate
the shell execution early by adding this
exit to the shell is in line ok let's
check in so yep a parameter passing work
let's try the failure case now so we
tell the script to fail and you will see
the expected output but you also see
some weird line appended with an exit
status sorry and when we check the real
existed as you will see it's one so what
happened here is the script was executed
the parameter passing work and they
shall terminate it properly early the
bad thing is that go run to for some
reason
masks the real non Z
exit status of your script and always
returns one and also it appends your
real exit status as an output to your
line stackoverflow people don't give up
they say yeah like I mean I didn't even
want it to face this here because they
say like we will add this weird huge
code which will consume the line parse
the real eggs like and at this point I
said no no no that this is just too
complex for a goal should be simple and
go scripting should be simple and like
if you check with spice and it's like
it's simple but that is too complex and
and what else they fail to notice and
this is like my Edition let's say you
have this go script and you go - that's
weird Stack Overflow approach you
execute it in from your shell it will
work but if you try to execute it from
another program let's say Python or some
other code you will see an error and why
is that to understand that you need to
understand all some Linux internals and
this is an interpretation by the way so
keep attention so if a new process wants
to execute a script it sends a so-called
exact system call which gets forwarded
to the operating system kernel because
there are different executive all for
months the kernel has different modules
which are responsible for parsing
different executable formats and when
you describe there is a bin format
script module which is exactly
responsible for parsing a shebang line
so when you execute a script actually
the kernel passes the shebang line and
not your shell and that module knows how
to launch your process so shebang line
processing happens inside the kernel
that's why it's works from any shell and
from any other process whereas the shell
is in line is the processing happens
inside the shell so it doesn't work
outside of the shell ok so what we know
that go run is no good we know the
chalice approach is also not good and it
has is very complex and it doesn't
support all the use cases so let's try
the shebang
approach one more so because like the
official go round tool does not do what
we want so we have this additional
people came up with additional custom to
go go run without the space which does
what what we need and so it's built to
compensate the shortcomings of the go
run and it consumes and I don't know
ignores the shebang line so it allows
you to have a hash and it returns proper
exit status so let's try the shebang
line will see custom go run to here okay
so parameter passing works let's try to
fail the script you get the output and
check the real exit status it's what we
expect let's try to execute it from
another process and it will work as well
but finally let's try to compile it like
I'm fed up with my script I wanted to
now compile it to a real program and it
will fail again
because we made an exception for the go
run for the scripting part but we didn't
made an exception for the compiler so it
seems I can't have the perfect solution
right I can't have ghost groups which
are valid go programs and scripts at the
same time okay let's go back to the
basics now what how can Linux help us in
this case when I was looking through all
the modules and Linux
I found this strange model : bin format
misc
which basically means everything else so
maybe I could use that and turns out I
can so bin format misc in Linux allows
you to register custom interpreters for
custom files and scripts so it basically
allows you to create your own acceptable
formats and you can nominate your exact
tables either by a file magic header or
an extension and surprisingly for a
kernel featured has great documentation
so it's very easy to digest the way how
you interact with it you you interact
with a special virtual file system
and you just tell it how to in which
files are to interpret and how to
interpret them so the simple example you
just first of all you check if you're
been format missed file system is
mounted it's probably is for a modern
system D distribution and then you feed
for this magic file this magic weird
strange line registering but what it
basically says to the kernel if you
encounter an executive will that go file
you should execute it via go run
interpreter like the custom go run in
temperature and the way how it works in
action so if a user process will try to
execute go file this exact call will be
forwarded to that min format kernel
module that kernel module will actually
see that it has a line registered for
that specific format and it executed
wire your nominated interpreter so the
real user process would look like that
okay so let's try it so a simple script
with nothing there is no shebang line no
shoes no quills is the plain go program
assuming we did all the magic in format
miss stuff so parameter passing worked
failure case no extra output here and
the exit status is as we expect let's
try to build it now and it builds just
fine because it's a valid go program
with no stupid hashes and let's try to
execute it from another process it will
work fine as well again because all the
processing happens inside the kernel so
you can execute this file from any
environment yes so now I'm satisfied and
yes you can use go as a scripting
language so some conclusions here go may
be useful as a scripting language who
still doesn't agree and catch me later
behind the corner
unfortunately standard go run - sorry I
was not man
to be a true go interpreter and go
because it doesn't accept any hash
hashes it can make any exceptions yes I
said go round was not intended to be as
a proper interpretive when you ask go
maintainer so why that invented and what
is its purpose so nobody can really tell
I mean if you know please text I would
really be interested in and being format
misc is a linux very neat linux feature
which can allows you to turn go into a
true scripting language if you were
attempting enough you would probably
also notice that the approach is generic
enough so you can just throw away go
here and turn like any favorite language
is the scripting language you can script
in Rus C and Java or whatever so it's
like a huge inclusive ecosystem of
scripting languages here is some useful
links I will share them later so no need
to take pictures if you want more
information and don't take my word for
it here are some happy customers of
using bean format misc module and go
scripting some of them are going to
present later so you can verify my
statement here and so yeah thank you
[Applause]
[Music]